anonymous you've probably heard of them
they're the group of online activists
that carry out cyber apps to advance
social and political change and
sometimes they need a lawyer a really
good lawyer
at first glance J Lederman seems like a
regular guy he lives in the suburbs
drives a fast car and as a
self-professed deadhead oh and he loves
whiskey but there's more J story that
immediately meets the eye
when Jason's down at the computer he's
anything but average
I represent accused cyber criminals many
of whom are either affiliated with
Anonymous or closely related groups and
it all started with a tweet I sent out a
couple tweets giving it attention to the
fact that I would take a pro bono case
the next morning there was an email in
my inbox from commander X commander X a
prominent member of the hacktivist group
Anonymous commander X was the first
activist I represented once he felt that
I was his lawyer he determined
unilaterally that I was the lawyer for
anonymous there are a number of
encrypted chat type programs that I
would prefer to use I like to keep the
NSA guessing with which method of
communication I'm going to use with the
idea that perhaps they can't monitor
them all at once when someone contacts
me and I do not know who they are it's
the most beautiful pure esteem because
there is absolutely no judgment on
anything over the computer everyone's
equal one of the hardest things about
representing Anonymous is working around
digital laws that were written decades
ago his main gripe is with the CFAA the
Computer Fraud and Abuse Act the
penalties are outrageous it's a bad law
it's a broken law it's not something
that fits with today's technology
sharing your Netflix password with your
friends that could be a federal crime I
hope that by helping activists by
pursuing these cases in the courts by
continuing to keep the issues alive in
the media that we can enact some degree
of change I hope it's not just a few of
us crazies running through
wilderness
you